bonjour et bienvenue dans filet co
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les titres situations de
crise chez Chrysalis cette association
d'insertion de Manille et amour une
soixantaine de salariés pour et bien ne
pas être payé ce mois-ci les chiffres du
chômage sont tombés petites hausses dans
les Yvelines plus 0,6% en février à
l'approche du deuxième tour des
municipales nous nous sommes demandés
comment étaient financé les campagnes
des candidats les éléments de réponse
dans notre dossier de la semaine et puis
nous parlerons de réseaux 78 un
groupement d'employeurs spécialisés dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration et le
tourisme nous découvrirons en quoi cela
consiste puis on essaiera de savoir
également l'intérêt pour les employeurs
et les salariés avec notre invité Karen
André bonsoir vous êtes animatrice de
réseaux 78 on vous retrouve dans un
instant on passe avant à l'actualité
économique de la semaine
situation de crise chez Chrysalis je
vous en parlais dans les titres une ONG
située au domaine du bulloyer à
Magny-les-Hameaux elle ne serait pas en
mesure de payer la soixantaine de
salariés en insertion à la fin du mois
une réunion de crise était organisée ce
jeudi après-midi en difficulté
financières depuis 2012 la direction a
déjà alerté les pouvoirs publics mais en
vain elle attend des subventions de la
part de l'État et de l'agglomération de
50 ans en Yvelines pour leur
l'association d'insertion n'a pas encore
obtenu déco favorable la période et
lectorale et l'incertitude des scrutin
rend les discussions assez complexes
59 420 c'est le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi de catégorie A dans le
département on note donc une hausse de
0,6% de janvier à février une hausse
plus faible cependant que dans
l'Hexagone plus 0,9 ou sur tout que dans
le reste de l'Île-de-France qui
enregistre une hausse 2 1,1% et puis à
noter tout de même une information
positive les jeunes s'en sortent mieux
le nombre de chômeurs de moins de 25 ans
ABC un peu de - 2,1%
le plateau de Saclay ne cesse de se
développer startup chercheur et
universitaire ont déjà investi les lieux
bien sûr mais il manquait toujours un
lieu de rencontre ce sera bientôt chose
faite avec le proto 214 204 pardon des
images de Michael Jerry
être un lieu d'échange entre les
étudiants les chercheurs les
entrepreneurs mais aussi les habitants
du plateau de Saclay c'est l'objectif du
proto de 104 cet espace de 200 mètres
carrés situés au cœur de l'Université
Paris-Sud car si le plateau de sa clé
est déjà un véritable up scientifique et
technologique avec son campus
universitaire 6 start-up et sa
concentration d'activités de recherche
et développement 13% de la recherche
française il n'y existait encore aucun
véritable lieu de rencontre et pour les
acteurs du territoire cela manquait les
lieux existent déjà les bureaux ils
existent déjà par contre que les gens et
le réflexe d'aller voir les autres et de
parler à des gens qui sont différents
d'eux bah ça c'est pas si simple et donc
j'aime bien ce genre de dynamique
créative le proto 204 204 comme le
numéro du bâtiment ouvrira ses portes le
3 avril alors en attendant Nicolas est
venu donner un coup de main pour
aménager le lieu ils envisagent par
exemple de monter le mobilier sur des
roulettes
interne seront organisés des conférences
des expositions ou encore des ateliers
différents espaces ont déjà été pensés
le lieu ce qui propose c'est un espace
de coworking donc où les gens puissent
venir travailler n'importe quand c'est à
la fois aussi un showroom c'est-à-dire
un espace de démonstration ou les
porteurs de projets puissent montrer ce
qu'ils font le mettre en valeur que ce
soit dans des vitrines que ce soit sur
un écran tactile ou lors d'un événement
on a aussi un espace de cafétéria ou les
gens puissent se reposer lire une revue
ou discuter tout tranquillement autour
de leurs avis à noter le proto de 104
proposera des événements dans le cadre
du festival futur en scène en avril
autour du numérique et de la créativité
et une autre initiative pour réunir les
différents acteurs du plateau les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie des
Yvelines et des scènes lancent un
nouveau programme d'accompagnement des
entreprises nommées plateaux Paris
Saclay il sera opérationnel en juin il
réunira 70 PME et 12 cadres de grandes
entreprises
le centre commercial Bel Air a
Rambouillet Innov désormais vous pouvez
payer dans certains magasins avec votre
téléphone portable un reportage de
Romain grabette et Patrick Jacques
deligue
ce mode de paiement ne vous dit
peut-être rien c'est une application
mobile qui permet aux clients de payer
directement avec leur smartphone ce mode
de paiement est disponible au Centre
Commercial bel air de Rambouillet
nous inscrivez après l'avoir téléchargé
vous activez votre carte bancaire dans
le cadre d'un processus qui est sécurisé
qui a été revu par les instances
compétentes en la matière et une fois
que vous utilisez en fait vous approchez
votre téléphone de l'équipement du
commerçant et on déclenche la
transaction de paiement au travers d'un
son on utilise en fait une technologie
partant du haut-parleur et du micro du
téléphone le centre commercial Bel-Air
et le premier d'Île-de-France à
s'équiper de ce système kips ne se
contente pas seulement du par mobile
l'application récompense ses
utilisateurs via plusieurs remises et
promotions dans les différents commerces
partenaires d'ailleurs près de la moitié
des commerçants du centre n'ont pas
hésité à s'acquitter des 10 euros de
cotisations mensuelles pour le terminal
nous cherchons un outil de mutualisation
de partage
des promotions et de et de cohésion dans
l'ensemble des des commerçants du centre
commercial pour répondre à des besoins
qui sont les besoins de clientèle de
fidélisation de promotion
d'augmentation du chaland du flux et
puis continuer à être compétitif sur un
marché qui est de plus en plus
concurrentiel au cours de l'année une
dizaine de centres en France adopteront
cette technologie avec l'ambition que
les clients délaissent leur portefeuille
depuis 2009 la marque Renault a décidé
de renforcer son activité de concept car
des véhicules souvent présentés dans des
salons ils ne sont pas destinés à être
commercialisés mais à montrer les
innovations de la marque et inspirer les
futurs véhicules sur ces images vous
voyez le Quid actuellement exposé au
Technocentre de lui en cours pour la
première fois le constructeur automobile
a lancé un concept car destiné
spécifiquement à un pays étranger l'Inde
ils sont déjà implantés sur place une
usine à Chennai produit les puls des
véhicules adaptés au marché Indiens et
les Duster qui se sont très bien
implantés ils cherchent avec ce concept
car ce nouveau concept cas a gagné de
nouvelles parts de marché pour faire le
véhicule pour les jeunes Indiens on a
fait cet objet là donc qui est dessiné
et imaginé un peu comme des véhicules
radiocommandés donc vous avez des roues
qui sort vraiment de la caisse donc vous
avez une carrosserie qui est très solide
donc c'est un faux 4 4
une sorte de Allroad qui je crois est
très bien adapté sur ce marché là en
plus quand vous vous regardez
l'intérieur donc c'est vraiment inspiré
de l'Inde il y a beaucoup d'objets qui
déroulent là-bas avec des banquettes
avant donc des riches cas donc on a mis
ici le conducteur ensemble avec deux
passagers sur le côté donc vraiment une
inspiration de l'air
et le jaune rappelle également les
épices côté innovation technologiques un
drone est placé à l'arrière comme vous
voyez sur ces images de synthèse il
permet de prendre des images de la route
et d'indiquer par exemple d'éventuelles
bouchons
l'entretien cette semaine se faire en
compagnie de Karen André bonsoir vous
êtes animatrice de réseau 78 alors il
s'agit d'un groupement d'employeurs ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
alors un groupement d'employeurs
spécialisé CHR donc métier de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration du
tourisme et de la collectivité
on est un plat implanté dans le 78 sous
la forme d'une association de voix 1901
nous regroupons donc les hôteliers et
les restaurateurs du département qui le
souhaitent pour les accompagner sur le
recrutement spécialisé en personnel
qualifiée cuisine salle étage
collectivité le reste voilà alors on va
essayer dans savoir un peu plus de
visualiser concrètement pardon comment
ça fonctionne je vous propose d'aller
retrouver Marc-Alexandre un cuisinier
qui a intégré ce réseau il y a quelques
mois des images de Patrick Jacques de
dexpud
Marc Alexandre a intégré la cuisine de
cet hôtel 4 étoiles en janvier pour
trouver ce poste il est passé par un
réseau d'employeurs réseaux 78
spécialisé dans l'hôtellerie et la
restauration c'est association permet de
mettre en place des CDI en temps partagé
c'est à dire créer un poste à temps
complet à partir de besoins en temps
partiel de plusieurs établissements
partenaires c'est la première semaine
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir aller dans
deux restaurants différents donc je
travaille trois jours dans un restaurant
et le reste du temps dans un autre
restaurant donc ici et puis dans un dans
un restaurant de golf depuis il a été
embauché en CDI à temps plein chez l'un
des deux employeurs un poste qui lui
permet d'exercer sa passion Marc
Alexandre est nantais d'origine pour lui
passer par un réseau d'employeurs lui
permettait de trouver un travail plus
rapidement
j'ai suivi mon ami en fait qui fait une
formation une formation d'équitation
dans la région donc voilà moi j'essaye
vraiment perdu elle elle a de la famille
par ici et moi je connaissais personne
via le réseau il lui a suffi de quelques
jours pour rencontrer des employeurs du
côté de la direction intégrer cette
association est un moyen de soulager le
service des ressources humaines c'est
vrai dans l'hôtellerie il y a beaucoup
de tornades donc ça peut nous intéresser
soit par du temps partagé c'est à dire
comme des extras ponctuellement quand il
y a quelqu'un de malade qu'il faut
remplacer au pied levé ou comme marque
par exemple dans les Yvelines réseau 78
regroupent une soixantaine d'hôteliers
restaurateurs et collectivités les
demandes sont permanentes et pour y
répondre l'association organise cette
semaine des forums de recrutement
partout en France
mercredi le réseau était à la Maison de
l'Emploi Rambouillet Grégory cherche un
poste de cuisine et avoir plusieurs
patrons ne lui fait pas peur d'une chose
de voir plusieurs entreprises
différentes plusieurs patrons différents
on acquérit plus de
plus de compétences on apprend plus de
choses au final avec ce système de
réseau l'association compte d'un côté
lutter contre la précarité des salariés
à temps partiel et de l'autre garantir
aux professionnels une présence et une
fiabilité même pour des extras
une fois que vous êtes alors à noter vos
organisez
un dernier Forum demain matin dans les
Yvelines plus exactement au Pôle emploi
de Sartrouville tout à fait tout à fait
j'en profite juste un petit clin d'œil
en fait on a organisé sur toute la
France ou tous les départements ou
réseaux et présents en France donc un
réseau job tour sur le mois de mars
juste l'avant saison d'été l'objectif
étant de de récupérer un maximum de
candidats ou de chercheurs d'emploi que
nous on appellerait donc les candidats
avant ces périodes saisonnières pour
pouvoir organiser du temps partagé donc
du temps partagé sur la montagne sur la
mer aussi du temps partagé saisonnier
sur le 78 en même temps qu'on peut le
faire sur une même semaine comme marque
Alexandre Lafay on le propose aussi par
exemple d'avril à novembre et puis un
autre poste un autre endroit mais un CDI
qui perdure sur l'année par exemple dans
le 73 dans le 74 ou encore dans le 13 83
donc à Marseille
d'un plus grand réseau on va dire qui
couvre la France
sur les départements lorsque les
professionnels nous y invitent donc les
professionnels qui entendent parler nous
sur un département où on n'est pas
présent contact le l'association de
réseau France qui est un petit peu
l'association mère en fait qui va
contrôler tout l'administratif et nous
accompagner sur la gestion et puis on
fait une étude entre guillemets une
étude de marché sur la la possibilité
d'implanter un réseau et on implanta un
réseau mais pour ça comme on est une
association il faut partir avec un
conseil d'administration avec des
assemblées un président etc etc donc
avoir des personnes motivées
professionnelles motivées puisque c'est
leur groupement d'employeurs et celui de
personnes et en clin d'oeil je dis
souvent ce ne sont pas nos clients mais
nos patrons pourquoi parce qu'en fait
l'association réseau a comme porteur
d'idées de les accompagner sur le
recrutement et pas de faire de l'argent
sur le dos des professionnels c'est
vraiment pas l'objet justement on va
parler un peu plus de votre
fonctionnement sur vos actions vous
diffusez tout d'abord les offres de
alors on dit toutes les offres d'emploi
de nos adhérents sur nos sites internet
donc notre site internet sur le blog
réseau 708 tous les mardis tous les
vendredis on a les offres d'emploi qui
sont diffusées et tous les mardis on a
les mini CV de nos meilleures candidats
donc nos candidats joker de la semaine
on fait des petits mots sur eux comme ça
tous nos adhérents et puis les gens qui
le souhaitent peuvent avoir des
informations sur eux et peuvent nous
contacter après ça on va faire des
forums d'emploi on va faire des forums
découvertes des métiers de l'hôtellerie
et surtout à trois quarts de temps on va
faire du recrutement vraiment notre
métier à nous c'est le recrutement ça
veut dire qu'on va recevoir entre 15 et
20 candidats par semaine on va faire les
prises de référence de tous ces
candidats qu'on va pas appeler les 10
employeurs où ils ont travaillé mais au
minimum deux anciens employeurs pour
s'assurer que leur CV est bien
vrai tout simplement on va leur demander
aussi certificat de travail et surtout
on va faire des des questionnaires
d'évaluation pour évaluer leur niveau
l'idée en passant par réseau pour un
salarié ce serait j'ai travaillé dans
tel type de restaurant qu'est-ce que
vous me proposez on peut lui proposer
beaucoup de choses mais surtout on va
devoir lui proposer dans un premier
temps un emploi qui va correspondre à sa
qualification et puis peut-être que par
la suite on va lui en proposer un un
petit peu plus dur et un petit et on va
faire de la montée en compétences pour
nos adhérents et pour le salarié donc on
peut vous comparer un petit peu une
agence d'intérim avec disons les actions
un peu plus personnalisées alors je
reviens dessus et je tire une grande
croix non non non non donc pourquoi
parce qu'en fait notre rôle c'est des
accompagner sur le recrutement pour des
postes en CDI en CDD et
occasionnellement en extra
occasionnellement pourquoi parce que
notre corps de métier c'est de lutter
contre le temps partiel sur la précarité
de l'emploi et d'accompagner les
adhérents sur des besoins en temps
partiel ça veut dire que quand un
adhérent a systématiquement besoin d'un
extra en salle tous les samedis et tous
les dimanches le but du jeu c'est de
trouver le candidat qui acceptera d'être
le mercredi jeudi et vendredi chez un
autre adhérent et donc cette adhérent au
lieu de faire appel à une agence
d'intérim et d'avoir pierre ce week-end
et Paul le week-end prochain il aura
toujours marqué Alexandre et on va
pérenniser en fait son besoin et surtout
la qualité du travail donné dans son
établissement on comprend bien ça permet
finalement aux salariés d'avoir un CDI à
temps plein d'avoir un contrat à pérenne
d'avoir un vrai salaire exactement et
puis pour finalement pour l'employeur
d'avoir aussi quelqu'un qui est
peut-être plus motivé plus impliqué
automatiquement parce que quand on va
régulièrement dans la même entreprise on
connaît bien sa carte on peut apprendre
de nouvelles choses on a les mêmes
collègues et pourtant on n'a pas là
peut-être la routine d'avoir au bout de
6 mois des fois les jeunes ils se disent
bon c'est bon six mois dans une boîte
j'ai envie de changer et pourquoi pas
garder un CDI pouvoir acheter une
voiture un appartement et puis changer
de lieu de travail tout en ayant le même
patron réseau alors concernant les
tarifs c'est aussi très avantageux vous
êtes une association vous avez quand
même des alors nous on travaille au
moindre coût je le dis tout le temps en
rigolant je veux bien faire un forum
dans votre vie mais gratuit pas cher pas
possible pourquoi parce qu'en fait donc
en étant associatif le moindre coût
c'est au jour d'aujourd'hui une salariée
structure donc un salaire structure une
assistante qui est en formation et qui
dans un mois va passer aussi en salarié
structure un bureau qui est
gracieusement prêté par la Chambre de
Commerce de Versailles qui nous
accompagne beaucoup aussi il y a quand
même mal précisé parce que vraiment ils
ont fait des bonnes choses beaucoup de
choses pour nous et puis petit à petit
bah comme le coup structure il est
minimum on n'a pas à la rentabilité on
n'a pas le besoin de rentabilité d'une
agence d'intérim on a tendance à dire on
ne se donne des objectifs de moyens et
pas des objectifs de réussite ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on va se
donner tous les moyens pour trouver le
bon candidat mais on n'a pas la barre là
à se dire faut faire de l'argent faire
de l'argent donc du coup le coefficient
et moindre c'est à dire qu'on va être
sur un coefficient en temps partagé à
1,77 dollars donc les patrons qui
connaissent le coût des charges ont bien
compris ce que ça voulait dire très bien
merci en tout cas d'être venu sur notre
plateau on appelle donc du coup les
candidats intéressés mais aussi les
employeurs à se tourner vers ce réseau
78 en tout cas un gros gros clin d'oeil
aux maisons de l'emploi de Rambouillet
de Coignières au Pôle emploi de
Sartrouville et au bureau de l'emploi de
Maisons-Laffitte qui nous ont
accompagnés sur tous ces forums qui ont
organisé les forums cette semaine on le
rappelle forum à Sartrouville demain
merci beaucoup on passe au dossier la
semaine
ce dimanche c'est le deuxième tour des
élections municipales dans toute la
France alors pour faire campagne les
différents candidats ont investi du
temps mais aussi de l'argent que se
cache-t-il derrière le financement des
campagnes des candidats réponse dans
notre dossier de la semaine des images
de la rédaction
pour briguer une mairie certains
candidats font campagne depuis des mois
distribution de tracts affichage
rencontre avec les habitants réunion
publique tous les moyens sont bons pour
se faire connaître et convaincre la
population mais cela a un coût alors
est-ce que le candidat le plus fortuné
est celui qui pourra se payer la
meilleure publicité non l'état tout
d'abord fixe un plafond de dépenses à ne
pas dépasser ce plafond dépend
évidemment du nombre d'habitants dans la
commune deuxième donnée pour obtenir une
plus grande égalité entre les candidats
l'État s'engage à rembourser une partie
de ses dépenses tout d'abord les frais
de campagne officielles c'est-à-dire les
dépenses liées à l'achat à l'impression
des professions de foi des candidats des
bulletins de vote et des affiches
apposées devant les bureaux c'est frais
sont remboursés intégralement aux
candidats tête de liste de conditions
qu'il y ait plus de 1000 habitants dans
la commune et que le candidat est obtenu
au minimum 5% des suffrages exprimés
un barème définit le nombre d'affiches
et bulletins autorisés selon le nombre
d'habitants de la commune mais aussi le
type de papier ou encore les formats
légaux pour faire campagne les candidats
ne se limitent évidemment pas assez
seuls dépenses l'organisation d'un
meeting les déplacements du candidat
dans le cadre de sa campagne ou encore
la création d'un site internet autant de
frais supplémentaires là encore bien
encadré le contrôle de ses dépenses et
confié à la Commission nationale des
contes de campagne et des financements
politiques pour faciliter ce contrôle le
candidat déclarant préfecture avant le
début de la campagne un mandataire
financier c'est-à-dire une personne
physique ou une association ce
mandataire doit ouvrir un compte
bancaire unique par lequel transiteront
toutes les dépenses et les recettes de
campagne cela n'est valable que pour les
communes de plus de 9000 habitants ce
camp de campagne est destiné à
centraliser toutes les recettes
et toutes les dépenses
que le candidat a mis en oeuvre pendant
sa campagne et ce n'est pas seulement la
campagne
au sens officiel du terme c'est à dire
qu'un jour avant le premier tour c'est
tout élégance qu'il a pu faire depuis un
an avant la date de l'élection ce qui
est une période très longue mais d'où
viennent ces recettes des éventuelles
partis politiques qui soutiennent le
candidat du candidat lui-même que ce
soit ses fonds propres ou un emprunt le
candidat peut également
percevoir par l'intermédiaire de son
mandataire pas directement des dons de
personnes physiques qui sont plafonnées
assez haut 4600 euros au maximum pour
une campagne électorale ces dépenses
restent limitées le code électoral
définit un plafond selon le nombre
d'habitants de la commune par exemple un
candidat à Versailles pourra dépenser
103.000 euros pour le premier tour alors
qu'un candidat de Magny-les-Hameaux
devra se limiter à 13 600 euros ces
montants ce mois juré au deuxième tour
comme pour les frais officiels les
bulletins ou les affiches ces dépenses
sont remboursées par l'État aux
candidats ayant enregistré plus de 5%
des suffrages exprimés mais cette fois
le remboursement n'est pas toujours
total il atteint au maximum
47,5 % du plafond encore faut-il
préciser que
ce remboursement et également plafonné
au niveau des dépenses si le candidat
dépense moins que ce niveau de 47 et
demi pour cent du plafond on va pas lui
rembourser 47 et demi on lui remboursera
au niveau ses dépenses et en plus il
faut que ces dépenses et étaient financé
par son apport personnel parce qu'on ne
doit pas lui rembourser des dépenses si
en réalité nuront rien coûté parce que
c'est le parti qui aurait aidé ou c'est
des dons de personnes physiques qui leur
ont permis de faire payer les dépenses
la condition majeure que le compte de
campagne soit validé par la commission
nationale et souvent elle doit effectuer
plus ajustements par exemple si la tête
de liste décide qu'on fera un repas
convivial entre tous les membres de la
liste pour échanger les des vues sur la
campagne
voir ce qui va ce qui ne va pas dans la
campagne etc
or la présence de toute les lecteur
cette dépense ne sera pas remboursable
parce que c'est une dépense fait à
l'occasion de la campagne mais pas
vis-à-vis des électeurs dans ce cas la
commission réforme le compte mais si le
candidat n'a pas respecté une règle dite
substantielle le dépassement du plafond
par exemple son compte sera rejeté dans
le cadre rejet il n'y a pas de
remboursement et en plus nous sommes
tenus de saisir
le juge de l'élection
au cas particulier c'est le tribunal
administratif qui est le jus de
l'élection dans le cas des élections
municipales de nos décisions de rejet et
si considère
comme c'est la plupart du temps le cas
que la commission a rejeté le compte à
bon droit c'était qu'elle a eu raison de
le faire il peut ça n'est pas une
obligation mais il peut décider que le
candidat sera inéligible pour une
période au maximum de 3 ans et il
éligible à toutes les élections pas
seulement à une future municipale ou une
municipale partiel par exemple qui
pourrait avoir lieu dans un cours de
lait éventuellement mais à toutes les
élections dans la durée qu'il a fixée
dans tous les cas les candidats doivent
déposer leurs comptes de campagne au
plus tard de mois et demi après le
premier tour de l'élection ses comptes
seront ensuite publiés au Journal
officiel ils sont accessibles à tous les
citoyens sur simple demande
et on finit avec l'agenda la plateforme
bouger vers l'emploi organise une
réunion d'information à la Cité des
Métiers à Trappes si vous rencontrez des
difficultés pour vous déplacer par
exemple pour vous rendre sur votre lieu
de travail ou votre centre de formation
ou aller à vos entretiens d'embauche
n'hésitez pas ça se passe mardi 1er
avril de 14h à 17h et c'est la fin de ce
fil écho merci d'avoir été avec nous je
vous donne rendez-vous jeudi prochain
d'ici là très bon weekend